[Música]
bienvenidos a nuestra crónica ambiental
hoy estamos en puyo ecuador que es
considerado como el corazón de la
amazonía de este país cuyo está ubicado
en pastaza una de las seis provincias
amazónicas ecuatorianas y en toda la
región habitan 11 de las 14
nacionalidades indígenas que hay en el
país ellas denuncian afectaciones a su
territorio son al menos 29 lugares donde
hay conflictos socioambientales en la
amazonía ecuatoriana como lo compiló
esta investigación del medio digital la
barra espaciadora el más conocido son
los derrames petroleros en el norte
ecuatoriano el canal de televisión
ecuavisa reveló que en promedio hay 10
derrames por mes en un país petrolero
por excelencia pues casi el 40 por
ciento de las exportaciones son de
hidrocarburos la minería amenazas a la
amazonía por la contaminación de los
ríos y porque en ocasiones entran
forzosamente a los territorios indígenas
la deforestación se ha disparado en
ecuador desde hace dos años hubo un boom
de la madera de balsa un elemento
liviano con el que se producen por
ejemplo las aspas de los molinos
la eólica pero para los indígenas entre
menos balsa exista más afectados estarán
por las inundaciones aceleradas por la
crisis climática ya que esta madera
absorbe grandes cantidades de agua
los indígenas sostienen que también las
hidroeléctricas impactan sus caudales
una de las denuncias más reconocidas
internacionalmente es la que hicieron
los pueblos de aíco fund 'sin and go
pues ellos lograron una victoria
histórica en contra de las mineras
ubicadas en el norte ecuatoriano
[Música]
estamos con alexandra narváez ella es
indígena y con fans de sing and go en la
amazonía ecuatoriana y además la
ganadora del premio goldman 2022 que es
reconocido como el nobel ambiental
alexandra un placer tenerla en nuestra
crónica de medio ambiente y bienvenida a
france 24 y lo primero que le quiero
preguntar es empecemos por explicar por
qué es sagrado el río aguarico que
defendieron y por el que evitaron que 52
concesiones mineras ilegales entraron en
acción es sagrado para nosotros porque
en la historia nuestros ancestros
nuestros abuelos mi abuelo me ha contado
que en el río más que nuestra
alimentación que son los pescados viven
gente cofán y que son las bodas entonces
por ende nosotros lo cuidamos
los seguiremos defendiendo por estas
grandes empresas mineras que quieren
destruir a nuestro río y que no es sólo
es fuente de vida de los cofanes y de
todo el agua agrio de toda la provincia
el agua agrio porque de ahí se consume
el agua para más de 90.000 personas
alexandra en qué consiste la guardia de
sin agua y cuáles son esas amenazas
externas frente a las que se defiende la
comunidad cubana
yo formo parte de la guardia y la
guardia hacemos recorridos protegiendo y
cuidando nuestro territorio por las
grandes amenazas que están en este caso
la amenaza de
minería también enfrentamos otras
amenazas ya que son invasores que entran
a nuestro territorio sin pedir permiso a
la caza la pesca ya la tala de árboles
grandes maderables entonces la guardia
lo que trabajamos es recorriendo y
cuidando y protegiendo nuestro
territorio y usted es una de las pocas
mujeres que hacen parte de esa guardia
como ha sido el rol de la mujer y que ha
hecho usted para reivindicar el papel de
las mujeres dentro de la comunidad
viendo que hay mucho machismo viendo que
no hay participación de la mujer que
nuestras voces siempre siempre están en
el piso digamos en esta no nos escuchan
entonces yo fui dije no primero tengo
que dar el paso yo para dejar un legado
a mis hijas de que nuestras voces como
mujer sean alzadas sean escuchadas y que
que la gente y el mundo nos escuche en
nuestro pensamiento nuestro sentir
nuestros pensamientos nuestros
sentimientos entonces
fui la primera mujer y pues ha sido un
camino duro en esta lucha ya que como
enfrentarme en las grandes empresas
mineras enfrentarme a la misma comunidad
entonces
el no
poder
que la gente ha símil eso de que una
mujer esté ahí muchas críticas entonces
ha sido duro pero aquí estoy y no ha
sido la única lucha porque también
emprendieron una pelea legal que
lograron que en octubre de 2018 los
tribunales se movieran 52 concesiones de
minería ilegal y luego esa lucha tuvo
otra victoria y fue en febrero de 2022
cuando la corte constitucional en efecto
los respaldo y reivindicó sus derechos
explícanos un poco cómo fue esa lucha
legal y qué hicieron ustedes fuimos a la
corte a decirle que si no nos daba una
cita para hacer audiencia nosotros
íbamos a estar en quitó en la corte más
de 400 indígenas protestando entonces
ahí nos dio
para febrero entonces llegó también a
territorio la corte constitucional llegó
a escuchar nuestro sentir los niños
también pudieron alzar sus voces decir
que nuestro territorio en nuestra
decisión que todo lo que afectará al
territorio teníamos que nosotros tomar
la decisión y pues la corte falló a
favor de nosotros
es fue una victoria grande hicimos
fiesta festejamos toda la noche con
chicha entonces esas luchas así nos
también nos dieron la oportunidad de
hacer conocer que somos un pueblo cofán
pequeño pero con mucha con mucha unión y
mucha fuerza de seguir y proteger
nuestra vida que nuestro territorio y
luego llegó otra victoria en mayo de
2022 el premio goldman lo recibieron
ustedes que es considerado el nobel
ambiental cuéntanos cómo lo recibieron y
qué ha pasado desde entonces cómo ha
impactado este reconocimiento
internacional es un reconocimiento que
nos llena de motivación y que nos llena
de decir que solo es un paso más para
decirle al mundo que nosotros vamos a
seguir en esta lucha vamos a seguir
cuidando el futuro de nuestros hijos y
de todo el mundo porque esta lucha no es
sólo para para territorio cofán esta
lucha es para todo el mundo que respira
un aire puro aún alexandra gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
gracias a ustedes y invitarlos a todos a
que vengan a territorio a conocer lo
maravilloso que tenemos y se unan a este
otra nación indígena ejemplo de la
defensa de la amazonía son los quechua
de sarayaku ellos lograron que en 2012
en la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos emitiera una sentencia a su
favor que fue histórica pues por primera
vez la corte dio todos los parámetros
para regular la consulta previa el
mecanismo con el que los estados deben
consultarle a las comunidades étnicas si
aprueban o no los proyectos de
explotación en sus territorios como los
petroleros ellos marcaron un antes y un
después en la consulta previa veamos
se cumplen 10 años desde que los
indígenas quechua de sarayaku en ecuador
lograron una sentencia histórica la
corte interamericana de derechos humanos
falló a su favor y le dijo al estado que
debía regular la consulta previa en el
país así la corte y dh trazo por primera
vez los requisitos para consultarle a
los indígenas si permitían o no los
proyectos extractivistas en su
territorio también ordenó desenterrar la
tonelada y medio de explosivos que
sembró una petrolera para buscar
hidrocarburos a hoy el estado
ecuatoriano dice que sólo ha sacado 17
kilos que la pentolita ya no es
peligrosa y que su retiro es tan costoso
que es mejor dejarla allí pero para los
que echó de sarayaku esta no es una
opción estamos solicitando que se haga
justicia porque esto durará muchos años
para que vuelva a hacerlo
al inicio porque aquí se atentó el
derecho a la a la vida del causa que
causa que sacha significa en quechua
selva viviente como reparación ante lo
que consideran un incumplimiento ellos
le piden a la corte constitucional
ecuatoriana que declaré la amazonía como
un ser vivo consciente y sujeto de
derechos el extraño no conoce porque
solamente considera que es una
naturaleza que no tiene conciencia que
no es un ser vivo y por lo tanto hay que
explotar hay que detonar y captar la
sísmica pero para nosotros una una
enorme herida porque nos limitan todas
las conexiones psicológicas emocionales
físicas espirituales que está conectado
con estos seres y eso para el estado
como que no le interesa los quechua de
sarayaku han sido un ejemplo para otras
comunidades indígenas del país de cómo
trabajar con entidades internacionales
para proteger el territorio y elena
gualinga lo sabe ella es una joven de
tan sólo 20 años
jose y de patricia gualinga dos líderes
reconocidos internacionalmente y al
igual que su mamá noemí y su hermana
nina se ha convertido en una vocera de
la defensa del territorio aunque para
elena el activismo en los jóvenes
indígenas está en la sangre yo creo que
los pueblos indígenas ya lo han estado
haciendo por muchos años no
y claro no se visibilizó de la misma
manera que hemos tenido los jóvenes
pero claro los jóvenes nos estamos dando
cuenta de lo que está en riesgo
pero también para los jóvenes amazónicos
los jóvenes y jóvenes indígenas es
nuestro legado es
enfrentado en nuestra identidad luchar y
proteger nuestros territorios elena ya
ha participado en la cop 26 la cumbre
climática de la onu y en estocolmo más
50 su llamado por la justicia climática
hacen de ella una grieta tumblr
amazónica
a propósito de la amazonía en brasil hay
una situación que preocupa la
desaparición del periodista británico
don philips colaborador de the gardian y
quien estaba con el experto bruno
pereyra ellos desaparecieron el 5 de
junio estaban en el río itajaí muy cerca
de la frontera que brasil comparte con
colombia y perú esta zona alberga a la
mayor cantidad de indígenas no
contactados del mundo y allí también hay
traficantes de cocaína madereros mineros
y cazadores ilegales
phillips estaba trabajando en un libro y
con él iba pereira un experto que solía
trabajar con la fundación nacional del
indio en colaboración con tribus
aisladas contactadas recientemente
su desaparición ha habido críticas
contra el gobierno brasileño le piden
que haga más por la búsqueda incluso ha
habido información errónea cuando aún no
habían aparecido la embajada brasileña
en londres le escribió una carta a la
familia de philips asegurando que habían
encontrado los cuerpos luego se disculpó
así llegamos al final de la crónica
ambiental de france 24 nos despedimos
desde la amazonía ecuatoriana recuerden
que pueden consultar este y más
programas en france24 punto com
[Música]